Nos piden resolver para "p"
y tenemos la siguiente desigualdad
-3p menos 7 menor que "p" más 9.
¿Ok? Entonces lo que esencialmente
nos piden hacer es despejar la "p"
y lo que casi siempre se hace es despejar la del lado izquierdo,
yo creo que es más sencillo
verlo de esta forma y
es lo que vamos a hacer,
entonces... vamos... lo primero que se me ocurre
es por ejemplo
restar "p" para poder quitar
ésta que está del lado derecho
entonces, lo que vamos a hacer,
es restar "p",
y para que la desigualdad
no se vea afectada
lo que tenemos que hacer
es restar de ambos lados y...
es decir,
pues para que...
no haya problemas
con el signo de la desigualdad,
lo que restamos de un lado
es lo que restamos del otro
¿Ok?
Y entonces resolvemos para esto,
del lado izquierdo, nos queda -3p menos "p",
que son -4p
y el -7 pues se queda igual
y esto es menor que
"p" menos "p", que se cancelan,
y solo me quedan 9,
muy bien,
Entonces lo que hice fue restar "p" de ambos lados
para que...
para que la desigualdad se siga conservando.
Muy bien,
entonces ahora,
lo siguiente que a mí se me ocurre es
quitar este -7 de aquí,
pues sumando 7 de ambos lados
entonces,
ahora sumamos 7 de ambos lados,
¿y qué es lo que me queda?
Del lado izquierdo pues estos se cancelan
y solo me queda
-4p que es menor que 9 más 7
que son 16,
muy bien,
Entonces ahora
ya lo que tenemos es que -4p
se relaciona con 16
y para poder quitar este -4
que es ya lo único
que nos está estorbando con la "p",
pues podemos dividir entre -4
¿verdad?
de ambos lados
y no he puesto la desigualdad
porque justamente hay que recordar
que cuando uno multiplica o divide
por algún número negativo
la desigualdad se invierte,
cambia de dirección,
entonces ahora en vez de ser menor que,
va a ser un mayor que.
Entonces del lado izquierdo
lo que tenemos es que estos se cancelan
y simplemente me queda "p"
mayor que 16 entre -4
que es -4
y esta ya es mi solución del problema
bueno, esto me da el conjunto de valores de "p"
que son solución
o que satisfacen esta desigualdad.
Si pudiéramos graficarlo,
por ejemplo
ponemos aquí,
nuestra recta numérica
más o menos así,
entonces pues digamos que por aquí anda el
-5, -4, - 3, -2 ,-1, el 0, el 1
y así, bueno.
Ok, entonces lo que nos dice esto es que nos tomamos todos los valores más grandes que -4,
sin incluir a -4
entonces,
le ponemos una bolita abierta
y nos tomamos todos los que están a su derecha,
que son los que son más grandes
y entonces, aquí ya tenemos graficado
nuestro conjunto solución de esta desigualdad
ahora
sólo para sentirnos bien y sentirnos cómodos
vamos a intentar algunos valores para
ver que esto si se cumple, por ejemplo
¿Qué pasa si nos tomamos aquí el -3?
Pues el -3 si está
en el conjunto solución así que,
debe satisfacer esta desigualdad.
Por ejemplo,
¿qué pasaría si ponemos en vez de "p" ponemos -3?.
-3 aquí...
entonces es -3 por "p"
que es -3,
-7 debería ser menor que -3 más 9,
vamos a comprobarlo,
-3 por -3 es 9,
-7 es menor que,
9 menos 3 que es 6,
y 9 menos 7 es 2,
que es menor que 6,
y claramente si funcionó este ejemplito.
Vamos a tomarnos ahora
uno que no está en el conjunto solución,
digamos... éste... -5...
entonces hacemos lo mismo en vez de "p" ponemos -5
y entonces nos queda
-3 por "p" que es -5 menos 7
es menor que -5 más 9
¿Ok? Esto es la desigualdad
que queremos ver si sí es cierta o no,
¿Cuánto es -3 por -5?
pues esto es 15
-7 debe ser menor que
9 menos 5 que es 4
y 15 menos 7
son 8
que claramente no es menor que 4,
entonces,
éste no funcionó
y qué bueno que no funcionó,
porque no habíamos incluido...
o el -5 no está incluido
en nuestro conjunto solución,
ok,
entonces solo como un último intento
¿qué pasaría si nos tomamos ahora el caso
de "p" igual a -4?
"p" igual a menos 4...
lo que sí sabemos que va a cumplir,
es,
si intentamos con -4
debe satisfacer la ecuación asociada
y bueno tú dirás
"¿Cuál es la ecuación asociada?"
La ecuación asociada es justamente,
en vez de poner un menor pones un igual.
Entonces -3p...
perdón, aquí falta -7
debería ser igual
a "p" más 9 cuando "p" es igual a -4
y vamos a ver que esto es cierto,
-3 por -4
-7,
es igual a -4 más 9
esto es lo que hay que ver
-3 por -4 es 12 menos 7,
debería ser igual a
a menos... ¿qué sería?
9 menos 4  son
y 12 menos 7 son 5,
que claramente es igual a 5,
entonces, esto está muy, muy, muy, muy bien,
sin embargo
nosotros no teníamos una igualdad,
nosotros en realidad
teníamos un menor que,
entonces si quitamos todo esto,
bueno ya vimos que "p" si cumple la ecuación asociada
pero vamos a ver que no cumple la desigualdad
porque,
si tenemos aquí puros menores,
puros menores,
nunca multiplicamos por nada,
entonces llegamos a que 5 es menor que 5
y claramente 5 no es más chico que él mismo ¿verdad?
Así que -4 no satisface la desigualdad
y eso está muy bien,
porque le excluimos del conjunto solución,
así que,
realmente puedes verlo como un punto frontera.